>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
BUILD BETTER AGENDAS IN FULL
MELTDOWN.
JOE PRACTICALLY PLEADING WITH
DEMOCRATS TO SAVE HIM.
>> WE NEED TO STAY TOGETHER.
BOUND BY THE VALUES WE HOLD AS A
PARTY.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
WE WON 2020 AS A UNIFIED PARTY
AND WE ARE LOOKING TO 2022 AND
AS WE DO THAT, WE NEED TO STAY
UNIFIED.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS ARE
WORRIED THAT THE TANKING POLL
NUMBERS WILL SINK THEIR CHANCES
OF HOLDING ON TO.
DANA, CHECKING BETWEEN THE
MODERATES IN THE FAR LEFT, BIDEN
HAS THROWN IN WITH THE FAR LEFT.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO HAVE TO CAVE
OR COMPROMISED BY THE END OF THE
YEAR.
>> Dana: THINK THEY LOOK AT
THEIR NUMBERS AND REALIZE
THERE'S A CASCADE OF A LACK OF
CONFIDENCE.
ALL OF THE ISSUES.
EDUCATION, IMMIGRATION,
INFLATION, FOREIGN POLICY,
AFGHANISTAN.
ALL OF IT.
THAT MEANS THAT JOE BIDEN'S
CREDIT IN TERMS OF POLITICAL
CAPITAL IS REALLY LOW.
HE DOESN'T HAVE ANY JUICE.
SAYING THAT YOU BETTER GET IN
LINE.
HE SAID HE WAS GOING TO RUN AS A
MODERATE.
HE WAS GOING TO RUN AS A PERSON
THAT WOULD REUNITE EVERYBODY AND
HE HAS NOT DONE THAT.
EVERYBODY GETS IT.
HE WON THE BATTLE BUT
BERNIE SANDERS WON THE WAR.
THEY ARE CALLING THE SHOTS.
THERE IS A WOMAN NAMED ABIGAIL
SPANBERGER, CONGRESSMAN FROM
VIRGINIA.
SHE WROTE AN OP-ED SAYING WE
NEED THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
BUT THAT SHIP HAS SAILED.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID NO THEY
WILL BE LINKED WITH THE
3.5 TRILLION OR WHATEVER THEY
END UP WITH.
DO NOT UNDERESTIMATE THEIR
ABILITY TO GET SOMETHING DONE.
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TO HAVE
SOMETHING TO RUN ON.
SOMEONE EVENTUALLY WILL CAVE BUT
I THINK IT WILL BE THE
MODERATES.
PSAKI MODERATES ARE THE ONLY
REASON THEY HAVE THE HOUSE
MAJORITY.
>> Dana: ON THE HOUSE SIDE.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT SINEMA AND
MANCHIN.
>> Greg: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
A SPAM BURGER.
>> Dana: HER NAME IS
SPANBERGER.
IF I MISPRONOUNCE IT I
APOLOGIZE.
>> Greg: THE GRAND UNIFIER
CANNOT UNIFY HIS PARTY.
CAN BARELY UNIFY HIS BATHROBE.
HIS ONLY PURPOSE WAS TO UNIFY TO
BEAT TRUMP.
IT WASN'T THAT HARD FOR HIM.
THEY JUST NEEDED THE VESSEL.
THEY NEEDED THE LOOK OF AN OLD
WHITE MODERATE AS COMFY AS MILK
AND COOKIES AT THAT TIME AND
YOU'RE WATCHING THE WHOLE THING
EMPLOYED.
IT WAS A TRICK.
THE VOTING PUBLIC IS SEEING THAT
HE WAS A FULL FRONT.
DESIGNED TO WIN AND ELECTION.
NOW THE IMPLOSION COMES.
GIVEN THE CHOICE, THIS IS WHAT
YOU WOULD HAVE DONE.
DO YOU WANT THE BERNIE SANDERS
OR DO YOU WANT TO PRETEND TO BE
SOMETHING ELSE ON WIN?
THEY STILL WON.
THEY PULLED THE WOOL, IF I MIGHT
SAY SO, OVER OUR EYES.
>> Jesse: THE POLL CAME OUT,
NO ONE KNOWS WHAT'S IN IT.
NO ONE THINKS IT'S GOING TO HELP
THE ECONOMY OR THEIR FAMILIES.
WHATEVER THEY ARE PUSHING,
INFRASTRUCTURE, BUILD BACK
BETTER, NO ONE KNOWS WHAT'S IN
IT.
>> Dagen: THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE SMART DESPITE THE WAY BIDEN
AND COMPANY SPEAK TO THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY AND THEY
KNOW THAT INFLATION IS SPIKING.
YOU HAVE A VARIETY OF
COMMODITIES THAT ARE NEAR OR AT
ALL-TIME HIGHS.
GASOLINE PRICES AT A SEVEN YEAR
HIGH.
THEY LOOK AT $5 TRILLION IN THIS
NEW WELFARE MONSTROSITY AND THEY
THINK MORE MONEY EQUALS MORE
INFLATION DESPITE WHAT JEN PSAKI
SAYS THAT WE NEED TO SPEND MONEY
TO SOLVE THE INFLATION PROBLEM.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
THEY ARE NOT BEHIND IT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
FOR THAT VERY REASON.
HOWEVER, JOE BIDEN IS STANDING
UP THERE LIKE WILLIE LOMAN,
TRYING TO SELL IT TO AMERICA.
IN TERMS OF UNITY, I THINK
48 OUT OF 50 DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
IN FAVOR OF THIS NEW CENTURY
WELFARE MONSTROSITY IS PRETTY
GOOD.
96% OF THE DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE PARTY THAT
THERE ARE ONLY TWO PEOPLE SAYING
SOCIAL SECURITY AND MEDICARE,
$112 TRILLION.
MEDICAL OR HOSPITAL FUNDS
RUNNING OUT OF MONEY.
THERE'S NOBODY THERE.
>> Jesse: IS JOE BIDEN WORKING
THE PHONES UNKNOWN IS LISTENING?
IS HE NOT WORKING THE PHONES?
>> HE SHOULD BE WORKING THE
PHONES.
THE ONLY THING HE SHOULD BE
SAYING IS THAT THE COUNTRY IS
PREPARED TO PASS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN.
LET'S DO IT.
SEE HOW THE COUNTRY DIGEST THE
FIRST SET OF THINGS.
>> Dana: HE ALREADY SAID NO.
HE WENT TO THE HILL.
>> HE CAN CHANGE HIS MIND.
IF HE IS GOING TO FIND HIS WAY
TO HIGHER GROUND, HE'S GOT TO DO
IT.
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT, HE WAS ELECTED
ON COVID AND I THINK HIS NUMBERS
ARE FALLING LARGELY BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE SAYING MY LIVES ARE
NOT NORMAL.
EVEN THE FIRST STORY, THE
SOUTHWEST PILOTS SAYING WHAT'S
WRONG?
WHY CAN'T WE GET SOME NORMALCY.
PEOPLE COME AT IT FROM DIFFERENT
WAYS.
DAGEN AND I MIGHT DISAGREE BUT
WE WANT THE MATTER RESOLVED AND
WE ARE NOT THERE.
HIS STABILITY AND CONFIDENCE.
MY PAL THIN CONGRESS, THEY SEEM
TO THINK THEY HAVE A 50 SEAT
MAJORITY IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
YOU DON'T.
IF YOU GET THERE, THEN YOU CAN
COME BACK AND PERHAPS TO SOME OF
THESE THINGS.
THE COUNTRY WOULD'VE SAID THIS
IS WHAT WE WANT.
THE COUNTRY IS WILLING TO GO
FORWARD ON SOME THINGS.
THE THING THEY ARE WILLING GO
FORWARD ON IS WHAT JOE BIDEN AND
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IN THE
SENATE NEGOTIATED.
PASS IT FIRST.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE MAKING A LOT